joining us now florida senator marco
rubio senator you're on the important
intel committee when you were on this
program last week you told me you told
this audience that in fact you and
everybody on the intel committee was
warning i'm going to put up a map
senator we played it in our opening
monologue in this map is the timeline of
the taliban on the march as you can see
april of 2021 may of 2021 the red that
fills up this map you know now june and
july of 2021 the taliban was on the
march the whole time senator you saw it
intel members saw it joe biden had to be
told i understand the cia pulled their
people out six weeks ago senator
why didn't why did joe wait to the last
minute yeah
you know when history looks back at this
moment and it's going to look back at
this moment this is going to be i mean
this is going to be a big deal for
decades this is going to be covered as
one of the worst catastrophes in
american foreign policy history for two
reasons number one is everything you
just said right now the failure of this
administration to anticipate what they
should have known what what the red
lights were flashing the whole time that
the taliban was moving faster than they
were talking about and the whole time
they were oblivious to it it seemed and
then the botching of this evacuation of
this entire uh process this is the way
the process should have worked okay the
way what joe biden should have said is
we have these people and we have this
equipment and we're going to get it out
of afghanistan and we'll leave once we
have all that stuff and anyone who gets
in the way including the taliban who
tries to stop us is going to be killed
you will die if you get in our way not
august 31st and not september 1st not
august 29th not a date a goal the goal
is we're going to get out the americans
we're going to get out the people that
work for us and we're not going to leave
the taliban in air force we just donated
an air force to the taliban two factors
i keep showing this map with the dates
of the taliban on the march and joe
biden did nothing that's point number
one point number two
is joe biden is abiding by the taliban's
deadline now i think like you that the
deadline ought to be when every american
and every ally is out uh the french the
brits the dutch they have they have sent
their troops behind enemy lines to
rescue their citizens
why hasn't the most powerful military
force on the face of the earth done the
same senator because i'm looking at a
countdown clock of
six days uh 18 hours nine minutes and
three seconds and and and they're out
uh according to that's the taliban's
deadline and joe's deadline apparently
but that's not even the deadline that's
the deadline for the last plane to take
off the true deadline is probably friday
thursday friday saturday look it took it
took from april to i believe june or
july to get 1500 people out okay august
31st is not like august 31st is the last
day there'll be any american on the
ground in terms of uniform so the real
deadline is actually this week it's not
the 31st but that's when you get with a
white house that's incompetent a
president who seems quite frankly
oblivious to all of this the delight
you're saying americans are going to be
left behind
we're going to leave our fellow
americans behind
well
i don't think there's any listen they're
already leaving now okay the the troops
are already being downgraded now because
you can't just put 6 000 troops and
everybody on one big plane it's not
noah's ark we're going to put everybody
on there and get them out at one time
okay so the true deadline is not the
31st and they stand there every single
day and they lie to people what you talk
to people that are on the ground in
there that airport is chaos total
complete chaos unsanitary conditions
rapidly declining and these people are
all happy oh this is the most successful
uh you know rescue and history these
people are out of their minds this is
what you get when a president is
completely out of touch with reality and
then we have a chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff who spends this time
worried about white rage don't worry
about ray white rage general milly worry
about the taliban and the americans who
are going to be killed by them because
of your botched efforts now and ongoing
i i have no words
for the first time in my life i can't i
can't even respond to that
senator thank you
and uh god help our our fellow americans
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else